right I've just had an audience with Her  Majesty the Queen and it's probably the  least well kept secret of recent years i  delighted to tell you that Her Majesty  has consented to that the general  election will be held on May the 7th I  would expect prorogation to Parliament  within a few days  formal dissolution in early April likes  a few words about it I will be going to  all four corners to the length and  breadth of our land of all four nations  of our United Kingdom in every part of  Britain and I will take two people are  very straightforward and clear message  at the general election there's a choice  between the party that has brought that  revolution about you face a stark choice  so it's a big choice this election is  about moving forward and as Prime  Minister here at number 10 Downing  Street that is what I will deliver I  look forward to seeing you all can't the  campaign trail you know